hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank a podcast where we answer your
questions provide a dubious advice and
give you all the week's news from Mars
and AFC Wimbledon but first John give us
a short poem because that's what you
like to do that's why we like to start
the podcast today's poem comes from
Ogden Nash it's called everybody tells
me everything I find it very difficult
to enthuse over the current news just
when you think that at least the outlook
is so black that it can grow no blacker
it worsens and this is why I do not like
the news because there has never been an
era when so many things were going so
right for so many of the wrong persons a
poem Hank that reminds us that the news
exhausted and outraged us even before
the men and women of cable began yelling
at us and at each other and which also
brings us to our first question of the
day from Diana where should I get my
news isn't everyone biased so Dear John
and Hank does objectivity exist
basically I like how we get to the root
of the big questions that are basically
ongoing philosophical questions that no
one has been able to answer for the last
2,000 years I think that actually
reminds me that we got to the heart of
the podcast so quickly I forgot to
mention our sponsor you know we're going
to have sponsors moving moving on heki
aware that no this is actually taking me
completely by surprise okay yeah no we
are going to have a sponsor our sponsor
for this podcast and every podcast is us
today's podcast is brought to you by
John and Hank green co-owners of dftba
records dftba.com your friendly
neighborhood eat a l'heure check it out
dear Hank and John has also brought to
you by the Orlando solar bears a defunct
International Hockey League team from
the 1990s dear Hank and John which
wouldn't be possible without the
delicious crisp and clear taste of
Crystal Pepsi dear Hank and John brought
to you by Rock'em Sock'em robots who's
gonna win the blue robot or the red
robot you won't know till you buy
Rock'em Sock'em robots available now at
Rock'em Sock'em robots calm slash Hank
and John used the offer code Hank and
John to get 15% off and ensure that we
may
six dollars every time you buy Rock'em
Sock'em robots I want to see if Rock'em
Sock'em robots actually still exist
right now they do they do I feel I feel
like that we shouldn't use that because
like they're a real thing and we just
advertised for an actual product but so
don't
dftba this so dear Hank agenda is not
brought to you by Rock'em Sock'em robots
it's brought to you by the game
crossfire you'll get caught up in the
crossfire if you play crossfire from
Mattel Dear John and Hank brought to you
by Chuckie Cheese Chuckie Cheese the
number one place to go when your child
is five and does not yet have an entero
virus I'm just kidding I actually love
Chuckie Cheese it's true that I get
Chuckie Cheese still exists just Chuckie
Cheese still exists Hank Chuckie Cheese
is not only does Chucky Cheese still
exist I spend almost every Saturday
there oh now I love Chuckie Cheese I
might like Chuckie Cheese more than
Henry does um can we get to
question-asking western part of the
podcast yeah maybe maybe we should do
there was a question objectivity does it
exist where do you get your news because
there is no such thing as a non-biased
source of anything that is human I mean
here's here's my answer to the question
I try to get my news from multiple
different sources so I read The
Economist I read the New York Times I
read The Wall Street Journal I also read
The Indianapolis Star my local paper and
I read my tumblr and Twitter and
Facebook feeds which I try very hard to
curate intelligently so that I'm hearing
from Human Rights Watch and I'm hearing
from the Gates Foundation and I'm
hearing from organizations that are
focused on what's called like effective
altruism like trying to maximize the
effectiveness of your charity dollar so
I want to hear from lots of different
organizations and both news
organizations and other kinds of
organizations that are doing work around
the world to find out what's going on I
also get a lot of information from
Wikipedia which I feel like is a pretty
pretty good collection of human
knowledge not the best but good it's
pretty amazing that Wikipedia has
managed to not be biased ah like like it
is meant to be fairly unbiased and that
I'd really don't understand how that
happened and how it's possible but it
does seem that way and oh it depends on
the articles some of the articles some
of the articles are not great but but ya
know somehow or another wikipedia has
become an astonishingly good
encyclopedia there's no such thing as a
perfect encyclopedia even you know even
expert curated ones are not perfect but
it's very very good one I think that if
you're looking at things that seem like
unbiased news that you're getting a
pretty good sort of cross section of
unbiased news the trick is to not go to
any one source and the other trick is to
read the news rather than just read
whatever comes across your facebook page
because that's where the most bias
happens when you're only sort of being
exposed to the news that your friends
want to share or that or that people in
your you know in your world are sharing
if you're only seeing and having
conversations inside of a bubble that is
created by you know your internet
preferences then then the Internet is
creating a world for you that does not
reflect the actual right you end up in
an echo chamber surrounded only by
voices that you already agree with
instead of yeah being exposed to stories
that you might otherwise not I mean
that's very difficult to do that's one
of the things I like about The Economist
is they report news from all over the
world now obviously they still have a
American and European bias but there's
quite a lot of reporting from around the
world Hank I have another question for
you
it's from Sylvia Dear John and Hank
what's the most unusual place you have
ever peed I feel like that question is
kind of because you pee everywhere you
go right it's got a question is kind of
what's the most unusual place you've
ever been so for me the answer to that
question is the White House where I also
pooped no that's wonderful Hank
congratulations the most unusual place
I've ever peed is Mike DiTullio's bed
poor Mike Ditullio you're just going to
let that hang there I'm going to explain
that at all I don't know how to explain
it I made a poor decision and
I like Julio's life was negatively
impacted as a result I woke up in the
middle of the night one time and puked
in the sink of my of my bathroom and
this was like our childhood home yeah
and I peed in the tub yep
and I mean you pee in the tub plenty as
a person like that sort of a thing that
people do but but I just stood outside
the tub and peed into the tub yeah and
and then I went back to sleep and then I
woke up in the morning and I was like I
don't feel very well but I guess I'm
gonna go to school I'm feel very tired
and I got into the bathroom and there
was puke in the sink and pee in the
bathtub and I was like I should probably
go back to bed so there you go
Hank is peed into a bathtub I've peed
into the bed of a relative stranger when
I was in talks an intoxicated college
student I do wish to clarify though that
just for the record the the young man in
question was not in the bed when I peed
on the bed and I did switch mattresses
with him and do all of his laundry so in
some ways I didn't pee on Mike to
Tulio's bed I peed on a bed that was
about to become mine Joe asks dear Hank
and John do you see yourselves making
YouTube videos in 10 or 20 years yes
yeah kinda I mean like I don't know if
there will be if it will be YouTube
videos it will be web format video which
is the phrase that I had used to me in a
conference call last night yeah god that
makes me sick to my stomach I'm so glad
I don't have to get on conference calls
like that yeah it will be a video I
still think that we will make video and
I still think that it will be
transmitted via the little tubes that
make up the Internet
people laughed them on their computer
and iPad screens or personal device I
think that your personal device screen
will by then be installed into your iris
so I don't think that you'll be holding
a screen I think that it will just kind
of run run across you know your cold
dead eyes it's funny none of the things
we disagree on I think we will maybe
eventually colonize the galaxy and you
think that in 10 years we will have
screens in our irises there is no way
that we're ever going to colonize the
galaxy
that is so ludicrous I refuse to engage
with you further in the conversation
next question from Kayla Dear John and
Hank my two-year-old son Liam told me
that if he ever has a brother we should
name him Hank John do you approve of
this name and if not what would you
suggest
first off Kayla I'm flattered please
tell your two-year-old son Liam that we
are delighted that he thinks so highly
of us that he would name his brother
Hank John
however Liam if I may speak to you
directly for a moment um in what
universe does it make sense to name your
brother Hank John when the name John
Hank is right there waiting for you Liam
John Hank me hey it's me Liam and my
little brother John Hank I can see it
already you're at the you know you know
like you're in fifth grade and he's in
third grade and everyone's like oh is
that your little brother and he's like
yeah that's my awesome little brother
he's so cool John Hank I don't like you
imposing your values on poor liam no I'm
not imposing my values on Liam I'm just
saying what's objectively a better name
John Hank is definitely better than Hank
John it's funny because the podcast is
called dear Hank and John so Hank John
actually I feel like it flows better
well you named the podcast clearly but
no that podcast just it was you know it
that it named itself you know it's just
what it's what makes the most sense Hank
and John ah I would argue that it makes
the least sense that the older brother
John would come before the younger
brother Hank yeah but go near John then
you're saying John and Hank and you've
got those two ends next to each other
John and John and the Hank it's no it
doesn't doesn't flow Hank and John it
got that at the end of the Hank to push
you into the and Hank and John instead
of John and Link it's awful okay Liam I
think that we've decided that you should
either name your younger brother your
hypothetical younger brother Hank John
or just name him John and Hank yeah
that's good it's up to you Liam we're
gonna leave it to you we trust you you
seem like a real
Yuli good name ER already for a
two-year-old yeah i mean i gotta say i
have a two-year-old and she has no idea
that it is possible for her ever to have
another sibling because it isn't an
icelandic nerdfighter named colca asks
dear Hank and John have you ever
considered visiting Iceland best regards
considered visiting Iceland Hank can I
tell my visiting Iceland story you've
been to Iceland have I been to Iceland
of course I've been everywhere I was in
Iceland in the summer of 2008 so here's
my Iceland story Iceland is a beautiful
fascinating nation of 300,000 people
it's about the size of Columbus Ohio but
it's an independent country okay okay uh
so I land in Reykjavik Iceland with
three of my friends well one one one
spouse and two friends but my spouse is
also my friend so three friends and we
go to the hot baths immediately and the
hot baths are almost empty but very nice
very pleasant hot baths um out in the
out in public and and I this part of
Iceland itself looks a little bit like
the surface of Mars which is to say that
it's like boring and uninhabited but
there was still something lovely about
it
and then we take the bus into Reykjavik
proper and it's a large city with no
people in it right like everything it is
completely abandoned it looks like a
ghost town like if everyone left
Columbus Ohio all at once and I'm
totally freaked out like walking down
the road with my baggage behind me
complete silence I
it was the most odd and dislocated I can
ever remember feeling and then suddenly
there is this eruption of sound hundreds
of thousands of people making noise all
at once and they emerge from whatever
hiding place they've been hiding from
onto the streets screaming cheering
throwing beer at each other covered
their faces covered in the Icelandic
flag many
of them weeping and it turns out that
when we landed in in Iceland was the
very moment that Iceland's Olympic men's
handball team was securing Iceland's
first Olympic medal in like 60 years and
so I found myself in the midst of the
most wonderful party and people would
grab me or grab Sara and they would grab
us and look look at us and scream
joyfully in Icelandic and we would be
like that's wonderful and they would be
like oh you're American you've won so
many medals you must always feel this
way ha ha ha so I love Iceland I love
it's my favorite place I've ever been
coca I liked how there was there was
just not a single person in the entire
country who is not at that moment
watching that handball match because
again it's a nation of 300,000 people
it's like if Columbus won an Olympic
medal it was ah what a time to be alive
and then when we during our trip in
Iceland which lasted two days at no
point did anyone discuss anything other
than the mint menzo and all Viktor
apparently you want to go back to
Iceland did you know John that according
to a recent poll the majority of Iceland
ders believe in elves elves like Santa's
elves uh I think more like Santa's elves
than like tokens elves I think like cut
kind of the way that we would believe in
in like ghosts where they're like that
they're like little little people who
like get up to mischief and live in the
mountains well you have to understand
having spent two days in Iceland I'm a
bit of an expert in the country and you
have to understand that it looks like a
place where elves would live so I think
if I lived in Iceland all the time I
would also probably believe in LA I kind
of wish I believed in elves okay okay
another question Hank this one from
Dylan I would like to know if you two
think punk is dead or not and your
reasons for feeling that way
as a person who literally fronts a punk
band I hope it is not dead I think
you're pretty punk rock usually when
people say things like punk punk is dead
or that anything is dead it's because
it's changed uh and and looks different
than it used to look or acts different
than it used to look at it and that is
true of punk but old punk remains alive
even if you don't like new punk at you
could still listen to your operation ivy
or seven seconds or whatever you think
real punk is and those steps metal punk
songs still sound just as good as they
but I know but I think this might be
where this person is coming from more
from that yeah that's the thing is like
in 1993 when I was a sophomore in high
school I thought that punk was dead
because you know nobody was listening to
the Dead Kennedys anymore right
so it's it's maybe it's that punk is
different and in a way that makes older
Punk's feel uncomfortable because
all-time low is to pop punk or whatever
but but but there is lots of interesting
and amazing punk happening all over the
world and some of it is very underground
and independent which is what punk
should be so I think a lot of times
there's really interesting Punk
happening it's just that people aren't
taking the time to find it all right a
quick question and we're going to answer
together on three what is a pop punk
band or a punk band that most people
aren't familiar with that we would
heartily recommend one two three the
mystery series yeah I knew it yeah I
knew it we both love the mystery tea
experience another question this one is
from James Dear John and Hank I will
soon be starting a job that will have me
traveling a lot do you have any
traveling tips do I
oh god you like it John started on
traveling tips oh yeah it's almost all I
have at this point is traveling tips
here's my here's my truck I want to
start with one when the plane goes
that's normal yeah well when it comes to
worrying about whether what's happening
on your plane is normal you just look at
the flight attendants and what you'll
discover is that pretty much everything
that you're worried about is normal and
then on occasion your moments away from
a fiery death here is yeah I my biggest
my biggest travel tip James is this
you're going to be spending a lot of
time in mediocre hotel rooms you will as
I have memorized the layout of the
Courtyard Marriott hotel room so that no
matter what city you're in you'll feel
like you're in the exact same place
because every Courtyard Marriott is laid
out the same you must leave that hotel
room or you will if you are me anyway
descend into a deep spiral of darkness
so you must call an uber or a taxi or
something and go somewhere in the place
that that you're visiting uh that makes
you feel like you're actually there
instead of just like you're in another
Courtyard Marriott by the way today's
podcast brought to you by Courtyard by
Marriott fantastic hotel chain couldn't
make the podcast without them so so
patient their financial support I I want
to tell the story about a career
Marriott it's very short
I was staying in a courtyard married on
our most recent tour with hankering the
perfect strangers and it uh it was a
converted other hotel oh boy much like a
hotel that was much like bit much bigger
rooms but they had just put the
Courtyard Marriott hotel furniture in
that room oh yeah and so it was very
strange to walk into the room and be
like well it was like this weird uncanny
valley where it was like this is all the
Courtyard Marriott furniture and the
Courtyard Marriott art on the walls but
there's just a huge amount of empty
space was very strange Hague and I once
spent 34 consecutive nights in different
courtyard Marriott's um mister and ya do
ya like close your eyes and think of
that red loveseat Hank you know what I
mean yep oh that red loveseat it was my
it was my ground
while we were traveling you know I'd
spend all day in that minivan with you
and and nothing against minivans or you
but I just I just kept thinking man I
just need to get to that red loveseat at
the Courtyard Marriott in Duluth
Minnesota or wherever we were that day
anyway I don't know like how how long
are you gonna go on with travel tips
because you've done a lot of traveling I
do feel like vlogbrothers has been a
tremendous gift to my traveling because
it forces me to leave the hotel and do
something or at least to think about
something other than how much I hate
spending time in hotels and I know this
will be very foreign to people who don't
do a lot of business travel probably a
lot of you are like what what's so wrong
with having like be expending input time
in hotels and having you know people
clean your towels for you and having
access to room service and a minibar or
whatever and there are a lot of
blessings to it but at least for me uh
it is the the the the place of Darkness
and or to be honest it is and so well
having to make a vlog brothers video is
like okay well you have to do something
other than like stare at the television
which you don't I can't find the energy
to turn on and contemplate the dead
blank face that's looking back at you
through that off screen you have to make
a vlog brothers video and it kind of
like gets me going so I guess that would
be my other travel tip I don't want to
make traveling for work seem that bad
because lots of people enjoy it but that
would be my other big traveling tip make
videos or do something do some kind of
creative projects with or for people you
love just to kind of like feel connected
to your wider world so you don't feel
like you're just like disconnected in
this travel space and then lastly
definitely pick an airline and work hard
to get medallion status not that it
really not that it really means anything
it doesn't really improve your life in
any way but it's like winning a video
game it's like leveling up so it allows
me to feel like I'm accomplishing
something by traveling because I'm
getting closer to Diamond
status yeah that's what they want that
is their goal well it works and when I
get diamond status this year Hank and
Delta Airlines is forced to every time I
enter the airport shoot off champagne
poppers and sing uh we love you John
Green we do we love you John Green we do
then I'm gonna be so excited I'm gonna
be so happy that sounds very exciting
for you we have another question it's
from Emily dear Hank and John I'm hoping
you can help me solve a mystery for six
years now at the Indianapolis Airport
there has been a spanish-language
announcement stating that quote
effective of June 30th 2009 it is
prohibited to smoke in the Indianapolis
International Airport it is not
permitted to smoke outside on the
streets or in the parking garage there
is not currently an english-language
version of this message and this is the
only spanish-language announcement in
the airport it sounds to me like no one
in charge speaks enough Spanish to
realize that this sounds quite silly at
this point any thoughts on the matter
Emily you've asked the single most
important question facing humans today
why six years on does the Indianapolis
International Airport continue every 12
minutes to play that spanish-language
announcement that it is no longer
possible to smoke inside the airport is
it because they believe that Spanish
speakers smoke at rates higher than
English speakers is it because also why
don't they ever have in Spanish that you
need to keep your bags with you at all
times and that if a stranger approaches
you and asked to put something in your
bag you should say no which they also
air every 12 minutes lest one forget
that if somebody random walks up to you
and says can I put this dynamite in your
in your luggage you're supposed to say
no um ah Emily it's a great question
it's a question actually that I have
asked the Indianapolis International
Airport over Twitter they did not
respond I felt that it's time to retire
the announcement you can't smoke in any
public place anymore um including but
not limited to the Indianapolis Airport
and yes I am equally frustrated by this
and when I'm filming a vow
I cannot tell you how often in the
middle of a really great take they will
come on the air and remind me in Spanish
that I cannot smoke your life is so hard
John Green I know
thanks for empathizing buddy uh this
question speaking of hard lives and
personally specific question comes from
Kiran Dear John and Hank greetings I'm a
nerdfighter who was recently diagnosed
with ulcerative colitis and I'm heading
off to college in August I was wondering
if Hank given his own experience had any
advice about dealing with this disease
wall in school Hank you have ulcerative
colitis um what do you think ah it
depends on your severity uh there but
like is mostly about getting used to and
being comfortable with uncomfortable
things so letting your professors know
and your friends know that you might
have to not be where you're supposed to
be at all the times when you're supposed
to be there and you might have to run
off in the middle of class and just
don't ask cuz you know where I'm going
yeah and it's about like being
comfortable enough with your disease in
your situation to not feel embarrassed
about that or to you know be able to get
over the embarrassment of it and that's
really hard and it takes time and
practice and that's the only thing that
it takes is you just have to do it and
the more you do it the more you'll know
that people are really gonna be fine
with it yeah I feel like we have so much
shame around our bodies that diseases
like ulcerative colitis are kind of
doubly traumatic like they're obviously
physically traumatic but there's also
this huge social stigma that goes with
it because yeah we aren't allowed to
talk about pooping and we aren't allowed
to talk about like intestinal diseases
in the same way that we're allowed to
talk about right say a broken arm or
diabetes and I I just want to encourage
you to be as open as you can and to to
understand that your body is not is not
shameful and that making this you know
it's unfortunate that you have a disease
that's made worse by its social stigma
but um you know the vast vast majority
of pee
people are are compassionate and open
and will not be judgmental and will not
snicker at you and will understand that
you are living with a chronic illness
that is already difficult enough without
having to be surrounded by people who
would who would shame you yeah and it's
a thing that's going to but it's not not
going to be embarrassing it's going to
be embarrassing for you and it might
also be embarrassing for them but it's
just a you know like the only way that
we could move past this is if we pretend
like it isn't embarrassing
and then everybody will be like I'm
embarrassed but should I be and then
they'll be like no and then it's okay
and hopefully through a generation of
that we can have children who will not
feel like they can't you know have a
disease that involves pooping and and
not experience constant shame yeah I
guess that's what that's what I really
want because I do think that like once
people are exposed to it and if you can
be honest about it like Hank when you're
honest and open about it like my own
embarrassment it's actually done wonders
for my own embarrassment and shame
around bodily functions you know and I
think that it's unfortunate that you you
get placed in a position where you sort
of have to be a spokesman for it but but
it does do a lot of good and and
people's attitudes do change by exposure
and they become more more comfortable
and they stop seeing it as the way
through the embarrassing lens that
they've are always seen it through but
it does take time and and work and it's
not fun dear Hank and John I recently
finished my first year of University and
right after that I went on a service
trip to Nicaragua I have been thinking a
lot this past year about ways in which
we can help those less fortunate than
ourselves especially when it involves
other nations that our own is it right
to interfere in the lives of others and
come to help them as if we know best Kim
well that's a really interesting
question and I think for a long long
time one of the biggest problems in
global development and global aid was
this idea that instead of listening to
people living in low and
country's about their needs and their
proposed solutions to the problems they
face you know the US and Europe and the
Soviet Union would come in and say like
oh we have the way and now we shall
implement it and that was very effective
in terms of getting countries to you
know side either with capitalism or
communism but it was completely
ineffective when it came to development
and that's one of the big or one of many
reasons why low-income countries didn't
benefit a lot from development in the
development aid in the second half of
the 20th century I think the key here
and the key in so many places is to
listen and to listen empathetically and
to understand that people living in
poverty understand much more about
poverty than we do and they also know
solutions that we can't possibly think
of so instead of like going to a poor
country and trying to implement a
solution I think that it makes a lot
more sense to go to poor countries and
listen and then see if there are ways
that money or other resources can help
to implement solutions and I think that
kind of development is a lot of what
we've seen in the last 20 years and has
a lot to do with why we've seen these
dramatic reductions in infant mortality
in maternal mortality dramatic
reductions in malaria deaths and
diarrhea deaths it's because we finally
have started to listen but but we still
need to do a much better job of that
it's it's really difficult to to come
into a place and and have this goal of
wanting to make the place better and
then to not immediately impose all of
your values and and perspectives and
world views on that situation like I am
used to a world where you solve problems
by high
people and you solve problems by
thinking really hard about complicated
you know like this and I'm solving the
problems inside of the social structures
that I know and understand and those are
not the social structures of other
places they're the social structures of
Missoula Montana and online video which
are not Universal in any way so I I like
it's important to realize that when when
we are engaging other places and other
people who are different from us we are
the ignorant ones we have no idea what's
going on we have no idea how that
society functions and wanting to impose
and like sort of implicitly imposing our
worldview and then also wanting to
impose our values our destructive
feelings because there's there's the
thing where you where you feel like well
I'm helping and but like this thing this
way that your culture behaves upsets me
and so like let's fix that first is not
that's not why we're doing this we're
doing this so that fewer babies will die
and so that people will live longer and
have happier healthier lives that's the
that's the first step and and like this
thing that happened for a long time
where the first step was to impose your
values along with whatever aid you were
giving was yeah and we still don't do a
great job of not doing that I mean the
the health care system in the developing
world that I know best is is the
Ethiopian health care system and one of
the biggest successes that they've
experienced in the last 15 years is with
volunteers it's with female volunteers
in rural communities who go out and talk
to their neighbors about prenatal care
about how when it's time to have a baby
how to get to the health care centre or
if necessary to get to a hospital and
those are people who aren't paid like
that that's very counter to my
understanding of how you solve
healthcare problems because I live in a
country where we spend 20 percent of our
GDP on healthcare and
and so I remember talking to a woman and
saying like I don't want to sound like a
you know like a filthy capitalist but
like why do you do this like you know
like you have a lot of other work and
you have a lot of other responsibilities
why do you do this and she she pointed
out to me that that is not a question
that I would ask if I had seen a lot of
babies die
this uh this brings to mind the fact
that I I have put this podcast in the
comedy section which I feel like it
belongs there like I'm glad I did that
it's nonstop comedy our only negative
review so far on iTunes has the subject
line comedy question mark question mark
and then the text was something like
this podcast was so depressing why do I
have to think about the fact that we're
never going to explore the galaxy and
the answer to that is that we are never
going to explore the galaxy it's not my
fault and its various that's amazing um
is that that's the most depressing thing
you took away from that episode not that
the lifespan of the human is
inconsequential anyway it's just just
good old-fashioned comedy do you want to
know I put it in the comedy section yes
I was going through the sections and
they kept asking me to subcategorize
mm-hmm like if I picked what it'd be
like so which which of these
subcategories and I was like that's too
much work and when I clicked comedy
there were no subcategories laziness the
key to podcasting success hey I think
it's time to talk about the news from
AFC Wimbledon the most important
football club in the world
owned by its fans built by its
supporters and of course Mars which is a
cold dead lifeless Rock orbiting around
the Sun uh what's the news from Mars
this week uh in Mars news the trailer
for the upcoming film of the Martian was
released and I'm very excited about it I
don't know if I'll actually be able to
go see the movie because I'm I'm like
that excited about it I feel like I
might need to see it in private ah
because what is very-- it's there it's
it's an adaptation of Andy Weir's book
the Martian uh-huh and it's about an
astronaut played by Matt Damon who is
one of my favorite people yeah
Matt Damon is is lost in a dust storm as
they are evacuating Mars because of this
dust storm oka and presumed dead but
then he ends up to not be dead and he
has to stay alive for years on thirty
days of supplies it's basically it's
like it's just weird engineering it's
just it just him like sciencing on
things for for you know 300 pages it's
amazing it's it is the most like it is
the most intense and wonderful
experience reading I have had with a
science fiction book in a long time and
I absolutely suggest anyone check it out
and it's but in like the fact that
they're turning into movie is weird
because it's going to be you know it's
it's like the whole book like it mostly
has one character because it's a guy
who's alone by himself on Mars right
they did that with a they did that with
I am Legend yeah which didn't turn out
well
oh I thought I am Legend was totally
watchable I didn't watch it I've only
heard that it didn't turn out well you
know people are always so hard on Will
Smith movies but just like Tom Cruise
movies I find them to be solidly
viewable I feel they distract me from
the void which is the number one thing
that I ask of films yeah oh well maybe
I'll check it out does it have zombies
uh it doesn't have zombies exactly but
it has sort of it that they have zombies
of a kind yes it's a it's a it's a
zombie like Phil I don't that they'll
scare me a lot I get very scared oh well
I will tell you it is a it is a fairly
scary movie it's one of those movies
where like everything's pretty chill you
get the feeling that like Will Smith
leads and overall a pretty high stress
life due to being the only known human
on earth but so you always feel this
like medium level of anxiety but then
like out of nowhere there will be you
know a zombie like vampire-like creature
and that that those parts are a little
bit upsetting but what I do is I just
cover my eyes during sixty to seventy
percent of those movies um
and I just wait for wait for the
inevitable cure to the zombie disease
that will inevitably result in like Will
Smith being reunited with his family and
etc Hank uh that by the way is again not
news from Mars it's news uh let me ask
you a question John if they were making
a movie out of AFC Wimbledon's story
would that not be your AFC Wimbledon
news this week actually it would not
just because the actual news from AFC
Wimbledon is so great okay I'm bad
believe that for a moment Hank Hank Hank
are you sitting down
that would be weird if I was recording a
podcast standing up Auto bio Aachen
phenoix the most important soccer player
for AFC Wimbledon the strongest man in
professional soccer according to the
video game FIFA the cult hero of AFC
Wimbledon he's big he's tough and he's
just signed a two-year contract he's
staying at the club
despite offers from several American
clubs in Major League Soccer Auto bio
Aachen phenoix also known as the beast
is staying with AFC Wimbledon it's it's
huge news up he loves the club he loves
that it's owned by its fans and he
turned down offers to come to America
for it he's had a fascinating career
Aachen phenoix he started out in his
professional career in Lithuania he's
always been told that he was too big to
be a professional football player Hank I
don't know if you're googling an image
of him right now but you should and he
he started out in Lithuania he once
played for five clubs in a single season
in England but finally he has found his
home where he is acknowledged and loved
for the incredible player and person
that he is and that home is AFC
Wimbledon we are so delighted that he is
staying with the club I yelped for joy
Hank as you know I've had a pretty good
couple of years in terms of professional
and-and-and and man my personal life I
had I had a child at a movie come out
very successful nothing has made me feel
as good as auto biohacking phenoix
re-signing
with AFC Wimbledon it is just pure joy I
have to say that this is not what soccer
players look like he's a big man he is a
big man
I actually remember watch I watched
whatever the recent important sport
thing was and I remember seeing him on
the on the pitch and being like that is
uh that is yeah different he is strong
yeah he he he actually has a line of
clothing called beast mode on because he
calls himself the beast and when he gets
out on the pitch he turns the beast mode
on yeah because in real life he's a very
quiet incredibly charismatic person one
of the most like likable intelligent
funny athletes I've ever heard
interviewed but then when he gets on the
pitch he's got to turn beast mode on and
he is just brilliant he scored against
Liverpool last season Hank he is the
real deal and I truly believe that with
bio as as we call him we have a very
good chance AFC Wimbledon of going up to
League One the third tier of English
football and then no one could make the
case that Mars is more important than
AFC Wimbledon we have news in the
podcast as well we have an editor for
the podcast Nicholas Jenkins whose name
you might know from being the producer
and director of crash course here in
Missoula so Nick is going to be thank
you Nick you are awesome in other
podcast news we held the second top spot
on iTunes as our podcast in America but
we were we were pushed out of number one
because Stephen Colbert and his new his
new nighttime show pushed us out of the
top spot I don't know why he had to
launch his podcast the same time we
launched ours but we did you serve him
in Canada and the United Kingdom which
are of course countries that are way
more important than the u.s. because our
podcast is popular in places where
people get free health care it's not
free they have to pay taxes for it it
just it just seems free because we pay
more taxes for health care and don't get
universal
health care so that's why right that's
why you were confused also I tweeted to
let people know that that Steven was
keeping us out of the top spot and they
should go subscribe if they want us to
make it there which we of course did not
but Steven tweeted back at me and he
said add Hank green sorry my anglerfish
based music is just better than yours
hashtag yours is good though hashtag
can't hate the night hashtag song
wednesday hashtag i run this pod down
hashtag song wednesday implies that
stephen colbert watch vlogbrothers in
2007 which i think is very unlikely
because i I feel like I was almost
personally acquainted with everyone who
watched vlogbrothers in 2007 and I don't
recall any of them having a cable show
right now yeah I feel like we would have
like recognized that screen name yeah
but I don't know I bet he has some
minions who tweet for him too
who knows if it was the actual Stephen
Colbert but regardless Thank You Stephen
don't ruin my dreams
it was the actual Stephen Colbert just
because you've been on the Stephen
Colbert show and you've like touched him
doesn't mean that like I don't need
validation John yeah sancai you are
suffering so mightily from a lack of
outside validation I don't know how you
get through the days um so thanks to
Stephen Colbert for ruining our dreams
of having a number one podcast thanks to
all of you for listening please send us
your questions at Hank and John at
gmail.com and as we say in my hometown
don't forget to be awesome